Speaker 1: I want to mention this,
but not spend a ton of time on it.
Again, people are talking about Hillary
2024. I've actually seen some op ed ads
saying Hillary is exactly what the Democratic
Party needs in 2024. This is very hard for me to
believe is a good idea for Democrats in 2024. One
such article talking about this is by CNN's editor
at large, Chris Cillizza. It's an article called
The Whispers of Hillary Clinton 2024 have started.
And Cillizza writes In the immediate aftermath
of the Supreme Court decision to overturn Roe
v Wade. Conservative writer John Ellis went
to the Internet to make a provocative case.
It's time for Hillary Clinton to make another
political comeback. He wrote, quote, Now is her
moment. The Supreme Court's decision to overturn
Roe v Wade creates the opening for Hillary Clinton
to get out of stealth mode and start down
the path towards declaring her candidacy
for the 2024 Democratic nomination. Ellis's
argument is one, Joe Biden will be 82
and is just going to be too old to run again. And
number two, the Democratic bench is not terribly
strong. He's not the only person eyeing a Clinton
reemergence going on to write that. Juan Williams,
the Democratic pundit, recently made the case
that Clinton should become a major figure on
the campaign trail this year to reset herself as a
potential candidate for 2024. I have two thoughts
on this, because I've been talking about there
needs to we need someone else. We need. There
needs to be someone else here. And continuing
to recycle the same candidates doesn't seem
like a great idea. Hillary Clinton is no spring
chicken herself. Okay. In 2024, she'll be 76
at the time of the 2024 election. So the idea that
Biden's too old at 82. So what Democrats need is
76 year old Hillary Clinton. I don't know that
that's like a super strong argument to me. But
there's this intangible feeling that even if you
can at some kind of micro-level, make this case
that the Democratic Party is just ready
for something different now. I've said
some of the people I'm interested in are Jamie
Raskin. I know anti-Semitism could be maybe a
problem for him, but I think Jamie Raskin would be
a fascinating candidate. I would love to vote for
Jamie Raskin. I think Jon Ossoff, the senator from
Georgia, super interesting, although maybe he's
not yet experienced enough. Maybe too young. I've
listed other people who I think are interesting.
None of them have the name recognition of
Hillary Clinton, and I can see that right away.
But it seems like exactly the type of mistake
that Democrats love to make to say, now,
let's go with Hillary once again, I just am not
seeing it. And it sounds like a disastrous idea,
but I want to hear from you. Let me know what
you think about this idea of Hillary. 2024.